[Music]
[Applause]
with over 3,000 delegates from 96
countries the FTTH Council Europe
conference is the biggest event of its
type on the planet this conference
continues to go from strength to
strength on a continent where similar
can be said about fibre deployment
itself and therefore delighted to be
joined today by FTTH council europe
president ronan kelly learning the stats
have just come out about europe this we
can use to be a very proud Irishman
today absolutely Brian they're proud but
mixed emotions in there as well I think
it's fantastic that Ireland has finally
made it onto the fiber of the home
council panorama and the entrance
barriers on onto the panorama are not
necessarily the highest in the world but
it does really show a necessary
investment in the country towards
building out fiber infrastructure so I'm
proud that we've made it armed but given
my role in fibre to the home council
Europe it's somewhat of an embarrassment
that it's taking us that long to get
onto the panorama that said I am very
optimistic that the level of momentum
has now finally started to build and I
think it took a while to get the engine
started with Ned at the start of this
really just a case of building on that
momentum as we go forward if I look at
some of the investments that are
happening from the likes of sciro which
is a joint venture between our national
electrical utility and Vodafone you know
they're really starting to build
momentum they're connect right now where
customers is rising all the time and
very optimistic about what they're going
to do in the year ahead in a similar
fashion the incumbent air has been kind
of almost matching home for home what
sciro is being doing on the number so
far and my expectation is they'll
continue to build on us I think we have
a lot of work to do around the National
Broadband Plan that's become a bit of a
disaster over the last year or so where
two of the main respondents in their
sorrow and err have withdrawn out of the
process so there's only one runner left
in the National Broadband Plan which is
e net doesn't really make for a good
competitive landscape with just one
player left in there so I think a
serious rethink is needed on that front
that said you know I think what we're
seeing in in Ireland is really being
heavily in
why what's happening across Europe in
general you know some of the other big
highlights that we saw on the panorama
Spain has now got to the point here
where we're hosting the conference this
year where they passed 17 and a half
million homes they've gone from zero to
hero in like four or five years they've
got over six million homes connected now
at this point so the momentum amongst
the customer base is really starting to
build as well with demand for these
services and I'm very optimistic we're
going to see this replicated across
Europe very quickly but growth also
causes a lot of demand how are they our
the industry going to cope with this it
does present a set of challenges you
know quite often when we talk about
countries like Portugal and Spain we
tend to talk about them you know they're
champions of fibre at home and we talk
about them in the past hence like
they're finished they've done if they
finish the build and it's move on but
they haven't there they're actually
still very much in full swing and
building out connectivity as we speak
and they're running our record run right
so if we look at the French market for
example they're connecting a million
homes a year so if you take that where
we've got the French market we've got
the empty Portuguese market we've got
the Spanish market all building out in
parallel we've now just seen with the UK
market and the last 12 months alone in
the UK market we've seen over two
billion pounds of investment money being
announced four different operators in
the UK market to go build air
fiber-to-the-home
networks so well it's fantastic that
we're seeing all this growth and
investment the challenges around supply
and supply not just on a raw material
side of things but also supply of human
resources to skilled people that can
design the networks that can build out
the networks the splicers that can do
the splicing work so we are starting to
hear a few grumblings out there that
there's a few pinch points emerging so I
know from speaking with the vendors here
at the show that a lot of them are
making the necessary investments to
ensure that we don't run into pinch
points as we go forward that there will
be enough supply of materials I know a
lot of them are investing heavily in
training of their personnel as well so
that the sufficient resources to keep
things going forward
and are you seeing any evidence of
innovation coming into the market or
without question there's a number of the
new entrants coming into the market that
are building out their infrastructures
that are adopting new methodologies with
regard to network design and build out
but also as well they're using new
technologies to light the fiber so for
the first time this year at one of the
operators we've seen in the UK market
now has started to deploy what we call
XJS palm technology so this is the first
of the 10 gig palm deployments now so
really what we're starting to see where
G pond technologies have served as well
for the last decade or so we're now
because the consumer demand starting to
see operators transition over onto the
10 gig palm technologies in a similar
fashion we're seeing technologies like
ng pond 2 which can take us all the way
up to 80 gig per pond with 8 different
wavelengths starting to see adoption as
well by some of the larger operators
around the world particularly those that
have mixed business models where they've
got a mix of consumer they've got a mix
of business and enterprise plus they've
also got backhaul requirements for their
mobile networks ng pond 2 really lends
itself well to that that's kind of a
hotbed of innovation at the moment
because there's a huge focus I'm trying
to drive cost out of that part of the
industry and a lot of success has been
made in 2017 I expect as we go forward
in 2080 and we really get that much more
relevant for the industry yes it looks
like we've got another dynamic 12 months
ahead in the meantime thank you for
talking to us no question I think you
know this industry never fails to
surprise me with the level of innovation
that goes on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]